I read about the Reckoning and you're
playing uh
I'm like you're looking at me like maybe
I got that wrong no that's right right
so was there any apprehension about
playing Jimmy or was there because he's
calling Jimmy Savile it sounds a bit too
familiar sorry you're right but um was
there any hesitation because he I rarely
used this term but he was a Monster yeah
I underped a filed now yeah um was there
a debate on taking on that role uh well
I thought long and hard about it Jeff
produced it
and uh you know I I didn't say yes
straight away
um but I thought it but you know it was
very well written the cast The The
Supporting Cast I had were you know
exemplary uh so it had all the right
um
uh all the things in place to make it
something worthwhile and not
exploitative or
prurient or morbid
um uh so I think it's a it's
and the script was very good and there
was a lot of care taken over it and uh I
felt like I could do it
um you know he's uh he provokes a very
very the the real revulsion uh when I
said I was doing a lot of people
wondering why we're doing it but as all
these things I think people
it's he is a was a fascinating
man and was able to Hoodwink a whole
nation uh because he was so famous and
successful and was at the time well
loved by people before they discovered
the awful truth about him
um but that that that by itself is uh
is I'm of the mind that you know to to
sort of prevent these things happening
again you have to look at them it's like
an uncomfortable process but you sweep
things under the carpet and try and turn
your back on someone like this then I
think the people a lot the boss is
because people feel the whole nation was
either Hoodwinked or if you're being
less kind complicit in enabling him to
do the nefarious things he did and so
um so it's important to look at someone
like that I think it's interesting you
know people play Hitler and play serial
murderers and no one Batson Island but
there's a lot of consternation about me
doing this
um but I thought but um as an acting job
it was
uh you know it's sort of what all actors
want to do is play
um you know whatever your views on uh a
a fascinating
um although you know horrific but
certainly uh a fascinating figure
who really is a manifestation of
something else that was sort of deeply
wrong in British Society I think that's
why it is it's not just about him it's
about what kind of uh Society
um lays the groundwork for someone like
him to to operate so anyway I mean I
think I think once it comes out it'll
vindicate itself I think it's oh I
actually agree with everything you said
and I think that it is important for
these stories to be made because and be
told because look at it even today with
athletes who do terrible things and
because they make so much money for
certain people they get away with some
really questionable things or the
weinsteins and everything it's about
power yeah